moi j'ai vu les critiques dont vous
étiez un peu l'objet la part des
féministes des wise exhibent leurs
fesses malgré tout et bien moi je suis
curieusement réseau surprendre suspecte
d'accord avec elle je pense que cet
attribut féminin que vous mettez en
avant c'est à vos fesses que longtemps
que fait des femmes un objet sexuel vous
en avez fait un objet de pouvoir et ça
je trouve ça assez fort je suis assez
frappé mois de 2,2 du cynisme du
pragmatisme et de la lucidité de cette
bonne génération par équipe et qui sait
utiliser finalement qui prend à rebours
tous les travers d'un société pour en
faire un objet de pouvoir et qui pour
moi l'aboutissement ultime de la
libération de la femme ça vous surprend
je voulais qu aujourd'hui je suis sur le
cul
[Rires]
et puis d'ailleurs vous dire à part si
la série mondiale inverse on peut dire
que le corps devient uniquement un objet
maintenant pour intervenir dans votre
débat sur tonton d'être compris ça l ont
bien compris je cherche aussi followers
quoi aller [ __ ] followers ya du flou
elle vendait sa confiance envers leur
façon extrêmement pragmatique elle vente
d'une marque sur instagram donc tout à
fait mais c'est ça fait vendre leurs
marques je suis pas avant le économie
insulaire s'est barré est tout à fait
blick
ouais voilà ce qui est des femmes qui
ont acheté des mots maillot demain est
pas ça oui dit comme ça c'est sion après
après c'est bien sûr alors pragmatisme
l'analyse instrument de pouvoir à moi
moi je valais totalement mais je vais
les et c'est un peu ce que mes n'aura
dit bien sûr il ya une recherche de
followers c'est sur ce même métier
forcément bien sûr je suis d'accord avec
eux je suis extrêmement d'accord est ce
que vous dites moi aussi avec ce que
dieu noah et après par contre moi je
suis que le corps de la femme dans tous
les cas elle était enfin c'est la nudité
n'est pas obscène c'est la société en
mai et qui fait que nous après voilà des
fesses peuvent choquer alors que les
fesses d'un homme nous assurons me
choque absolument pas il peut se mettre
et sam extra pas le moins du monde non
plus à bépanda dépend de l'âge du
propriétaire des femmes après c'est une
attitude d'être sexy c'est une attitude
de faire des photos ces natifs un ccd
recherche de contenus c'est un métier
mais moi je j'entends ce que vous dites
et je suis totalement d'accord c'est
comme ça que j'essaye d'expliquer vous
l'avez bien va devoir de vous voir
arriver je m'attendais à voir arriver de
bebo un peu vulgaire et oui et puis en
fait cette petite nana en ballon les
jours et invite la chine catherine c'est
quoi la même élection là vous
comprendrez que nous réunissions et
elles disent attrayant navires 4 et
bilbo mais je ne sais jamais la classe a
du boulot de fait à chaque fois dit il
ya une hygiène de vie etc
c'est pas non plus ne trie pas les
champignons fait pas et il m'a dit non
mais ça s'entretient
c'est d'ailleurs j'essaie de bientôt je
vais diversion monstre parce que je suis
passionné de fitness et que c'est un
énorme travail aussi de prendre soin de
son corps et j'ai beaucoup évolué sur
mes premières photos instagram qu'on
voit là à aujourd'hui j'ai été très
complexe et aussi par mon corps comme
beaucoup de femmes et je m'en viens d'en
coller
je me trouvais trop fine et c'était
j'étais pas bien dans mon corps est
aujourd'hui beaucoup de followers qui
demande comment j'ai pu évoluer j'ai
envie de leur faire partager tout ça
donc je lance bientôt mon application de
fitness qui serait mieux parce que ça
c'est beaucoup de travail cdd explique
allawi après